SPEAKER: Learn to
architect and develop
Android apps in the Kotlin
programming language
using industry-proven
tools and libraries.
Creating Android
Apps in Kotlin is
a course developed by Google,
together with Udacity.
You'll learn by building real
Android apps using industry
best practices with
modern app architecture.
Understand why and how to use
Android Jetpack components,
such as Room for
databases, WorkManager
for background processing,
the new Navigation
components, and more.
You'll use key Kotlin features
to write your app code
more quickly and concisely.
Learning to develop
on Android is
much more than learning
APIs and shortcuts.
It's training your brain to
think like a mobile developer.
Come learn with us.
For more information on this
free course and to see all
of Google's courses
with Udacity,
go to udacity.com/google.